I wanted to ask you about your first
impression of a star is born when that
script came your way did you look at it
and say oh yeah this has potential to go
around again or that's I'm not even sure
if I read the script before I had my
first meeting with Bradley it was all
kind of a fog at this point but I
remembered clearly the first meeting I
didn't know Bradley before we worked on
this I went to his home and had a meal
and we talked about our families and we
talked about life and we talked about
specifically about the film while I was
there he played a tape for me of he in a
voice coach that he had been working
with for a month or so and it was a tape
in which he would even he was trying to
get my voice down and I thought wow that
sounds a lot like me and that's weird
and he told me why and how that end and
what he was up to
I was very intrigued by there was if
there was not a moment where I thought
wow I don't know if I want to do this I
was in from the get-go did he ever tell
you what the voice coach told him to do
to get your wondering what that what
that trick I think it's all physical
somehow there's rarely talked about
anything to get any we had been walking
around with his head down like talking
like this was easy to do but clearly
that's not gonna work when you look at
you know performing in front of a camera
it's a matter of muscle memory you know
I'm dying to know about working with
Bradley as an actor's director - I'm
honestly I'm just astounded by the fact
that this is his first feature usually
and I think it just lies in the fact
that Bradley is clearly a very smart man
you know a brilliant man and he's also
as it turns out a brilliant director
he's got the ability that you know on
apart from all of the stuff that it's in
his head about what he wants to make the
movie he wants to make he has this
ability to set a tone on the set that
makes an actor feel very safe you know
and it just allows you to get at the
truth when you have that common
environment
one thing that I've walked away from
this movie really thinking about after
is just the idea of overcoming
self-doubt and how important it is to
have a support system around you and
also actually think about it and value
it so is there anyone out there that
really made a difference in your career
that maybe they don't know how important
they are to you I think the people that
made differences in my career do know
you know I had a lot of mentors along
the way coaches teachers you know my mom
was my greatest supporter until she died
at 97 she'd be tickled about all this
she'd loved this movie no I think I
can't say enough that I think mentors
are the most important thing that we
one could encounter along the way people
that care about you people that help you
on your journey
[Music]
you